Irán salió al paso a los señalamientos
de occidente
el alboroto que han iniciado los países
occidentales de que la República de Irán
ha proporcionado a Rusia misiles y
drones para ayudar en la guerra en
Ucrania la parte de los misiles es falsa
en la parte del dron es correcta es la
primera vez que Teherán reconoce lo que
venía en Boca de la coalición hacía
semanas pero para Teherán hay zonas
grises que los exculpan
proporcionamos un número limitado de
drones a Rusia muchos meses antes de la
Guerra de Ucrania acordamos con la
cancillería de Ucrania que nos
proporcionará cualquier evidencia de que
Rusia ha estado utilizando drones
iraníes en su país
las declaraciones del canciller
desmienten la versión de Moscú quien
había negado el uso de estos aparatos
incluso estuvo programada una reunión
entre Teherán y kiev para discutir el
espinoso tema pero según abdolayán la
delegación ucraniana se retiró en último
momento versión rechazada por Ucrania
que asegura que Irán debe reconocer su
compli
los representantes oficiales iraníes
emitieron una declaración hoy han
decidido admitir que suministraron
drones para el terror ruso pero también
mentían en este reconocimiento estamos
derribando al menos 10 drones iraníes
diariamente Mientras que el régimen
iraní afirma que supuestamente
proporcionó pocos de ellos antes del
comienzo de la invasión a gran escala
en las últimas semanas han proseguido
los ataques a centrales eléctricas y
otras infraestructuras críticas por
parte del kremlin el gobierno se vio
obligado a imponer restricciones
suplementarias al uso de electricidad en
kiev consecuencia de los bombardeos una
estrategia viable para Rusia ante la
falta de avances en el terreno pero que
castiga a los civiles de cara al
invierno que se augura